president biden running on empty when it
comes to the energy crisis the white
house blaming the pain at the pump on
everything from putin to greedy oil
companies
the invasion of ukraine and the
volatility of the oil market is no
excuse for excessive price increases and
this chart uh which you see here shows
both the price of crude oil and you see
where where it is as it relates to the
price of gasoline and as you've seen it
gone that go down the price of gasoline
obviously has not gone down i wish that
camera had panned over there so you
could see uh what was going on blaming
the oil companies it is a point i
wholeheartedly agree with i even offered
my own tweet at geraldo vera my must see
twitter account yeah i saw it write in
quote oil price is crashing make the
gouging fat cat oil barons pass the
savings on to the consumer yes crashes
it's crashing a technically it's down 25
bucks oh come on but what undermines the
president's position here let me throw a
bone to my colleagues is the fact that
the squad and other powerful progressive
house democrats are set to demand that
the president use his executive powers
to declare get this a national climate
emergency hey hey gang how about a
national climate emergency let's ban oil
drilling on federal lands it is a
totally judge a totally insane proposal
i'm confused are you busy what do you
mean i'm busy
you mad at me you're not gonna answer
the question i don't understand what you
mean yeah i don't understand what i mean
about about about what the oil barons
gouging parents
how are they gouging and then what and
you're saying how are they gathering
the last time oil was at 95 bucks gas
was uh what two something right and now
it's four something how do you explain
that let me just say how do you explain
that that's an observation geraldo that
is not absolutely i go to the gas
station hold on first of all everybody
wants to see gas prices come down it
benefits the american consumer american
families are struggling right now we
want the prices to come down but
demonizing the oil and gas industries in
a moment of energy crisis in this
country you have to ask yourself is that
a good idea why are there feelings so
important to you why i don't i don't
understand why the feelings for um
demand stories
why can't their feelings are hurt i want
them to lower the prices they're making
too much money why why are they a part
of the government that they should
reduce their profits they're not
profiteering they have a right this is
before
he says that there's nine thousand acres
that are unstoppable you have to care
all right let me care about it if you
have an administration that is slow
walking every approval if you've got
these places where you can drill but you
don't even have a reason why the permian
basin they could they could put their
own wells back online they just don't do
it because they're not sure that months
from now they're going to make the same
money so they want to tell you something
at a time when prices are so high there
are people who are willing to bet on it
just to get out there and wait
absolutely let them let them do it i say
let them drill drill you know
don't jump
west texas can solve the energy
questions you know what i'm just saying
for although the answer is they have to
be in an environment where they feel
like there's a business energy friendly
environment for them to want to take on
that risk and tap into the you can ask
them that's the answer that they will
give you but to your point about
accusations of price gouging that is
illegal activity and it is a bold claim
that he's probably damaging is a crime
private profiteering is not illegal he
just says price goes to the markets
price scouts doubting is not illegal
either unless you're is a crime whose
side are you on are you on big oil size
tuition goes up geraldo
what do you say do you say that colleges
are price gouging yes so you say they're
they're looking for excessive profits
yes they are they want their swimming
pools big tech makes all that money does
biden come out and say these greedy guys
they need to give some money back to the
people they never say that they blame
big meat they blame big oil you don't
attack a butcher when everyone's
starving yeah right what do you work
taking big meat and big oil really are
guilty of this big oil i said they're
the ones sitting on the nine thousand
they make sure how do they make record
products yeah those are smaller they're
making it perfect those are smaller
companies new companies making records
for smaller companies
whose side are you on big oil big meat
what about big tv
yeah
you know when there's news
well the money flows huh hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else